DeSantis okay how do we
or do you think that DeSantis can even
beat Trump
okay so it's uh almost at halftime
they're down 37 points how many times
have you seen a team come back from
halftime being down 37 never that often
right I was at a game one time playoff
game Rockets are playing the Clippers
they're up 28 points going into the
fourth quarter it's me and Robert Greene
author of 40 Laws of Power you you
remember that day when we were together
he's like you want to go to dinner I
said well not just wait two minutes and
then they benched James Harden I don't
know why they've been James Harden oh
boom boom boom
Rockets came back and beat the Clippers
being down 28 with Hardin on the bench
I'm like what what the hell just
happened right now couldn't believe it
I've never seen anything like that in my
life
so
hard in this case is who
DeSantis
Casey can help him win it Casey is very
unique Casey his wife his wife is is
have you seen his wife you're talking
about Casey neistat
case if you watch Casey in a small
setting oh my God she's on it tell
talent talent like you would have been
wins by you know attractive good talk or
smart intelligent supportive protective
defense to husband
has the story can connect with moms you
know can uh it's a very unique Dynamic
part that he has look this is this is
the best way to look into the sentences
who in here is the one that knows the
most about technology [__] breaking down
data statistic who's the most analytical
organized person in this floor right now
who's a person probably not Mark Mark
Mark I mean you put Mark okay how well
is Mark on camera good how how great
that's all right is he that's a star
he's a star okay this is their last name
what's your last name Gagnon okay
unfortunately he said what was it called
show called it's the podcast called yes
Camp Gagnon yeah and you go to you you
listen to two songs to get home right
yeah what was the song you said the Red
Hot Chili Peppers uh yeah give it away
and then black hole today seven minutes
to get home right seven or eight minutes
to get home okay now
fortunately he has charisma
but in most cases a guy that can go like
in my case when I was coming up on
Morgan Stanley Dean with her I had a guy
that was next to me he knew everything
about every product we sold I could not
believe how much this guy knew he would
do laps around the branch man around
everybody couldn't sell
yeah they have the Charisma that's my
concern with this answer the Santa the
Santa's can do laps around anybody when
it comes down to policies Constitution
all this stuff but he's going to need to
lean on his wife for the Charisma side
because even yesterday when he's doing
the live he just read for seven minutes
well that's the thing it's like and I
think he's doing the same thing that
like Hillary did which is uh
Charlemagne had an interesting thing
about like Hillary when Hillary ran and
he goes when Hillary ran she came on The
Breakfast Club and uh they teased her
about saying that she had hot sauce in
her bag oh my God forget that but when
he said he was now were you just saying
that to Pander to black people she took
a moment and her like robot brain was
about to spew out some [__] and then
she just went did it work and it was the
first real moment you've ever seen with
Hillary and everybody laughed and it was
like oh there's an actual human being in
here that's not having everything like
field tested that she's about to say my
concern with DeSantis is
everybody around him has told him it's a
lock he's gonna win so now he's playing
prevent defense he's like I don't want
to say the wrong thing that's going to
[__] it up for me prevent defense
prevents you from winning and I feel
like every single thing he's gonna say
is going to be buttoned down to the T
and you're gonna lose any Charisma if
we've learned anything you need [__]
charisma
and if he doesn't have it
he can maybe beat Biden
maybe but he's not beating that [__]
trolley one way he can beat him only one
way listen it's so funny you say this
you know what we talk about in the first
five minutes of the podcast how only the
parent would survive their Camp is not
paranoid enough that's the problem what
are you doing I'm sorry the guy won in
2016. and he is the greatest smack
talker of all time one of the greatest
showman not been a better marketer than
him in political space he came out of a
city New York where in the rooms he has
to negotiate with these are killers you
think he's intimidated about going up
against a guy like who are we talking
he's been he's building skyscrapers yeah
in bureaucratic nightmare New York City
I don't think people understand how
difficult that vine air he's buying air
he's buying like you can't build and
Delight in this like that that
negotiation is not going to be easy so
that's the part with the only the
paranoid survive when it comes on but
the way one of the ways that they could
be relying on Trump uh uh under Santa's
winning
sometimes when a person comes in and
they're a little too confident they know
something we don't know and I don't know
what this is listen I'm not starting
anything here but here's what I mean I
said we'll start that [__] here's what I
mean by so if if they're banking on the
reason why they keep delaying delaying
delaying delay in the lane because they
think the law would have prevented them
having to even get ugly and rather they
wanted to delay it so far so Trump gets
arrested and he can't run and then they
come out and he says look I don't care
what you say if it wasn't for the
president I would have never been a
governor I wouldn't know to win the Mega
vote and I I think there's a little bit
of that where maybe they will relying on
the law to make this thing easier now
you have to fight the guy so DeSantis
thought that he was going to get locked
up and then if he did get locked up he
doesn't he would defend him he would
defend and then take all the magazines
it's the smartest thing in the world
you wanna talk about bureaucracy there's
nothing more bureaucratic than locking
up a billionaire yeah I mean that's
gonna I think the DNC maybe are like
holding the real serious [__] about
Trump wait to them to like
fight it out in the mud and then
you know so so these guys are well the
Democrats want Trump to be the face the
Democrats want Trump to win the
Democrats want Trump to win because they
know they can beat them again because
the Democrats okay cool let's play that
out if that's the case
Alvin Bragg I'm sorry why do you do that
oh because it helps them I don't know if
it helps them the pictures of him being
in court well you know with the
Mar-A-Lago FBI what because that helped
no it doesn't help what like if you
really think he's the guy help him beat
the scientist yeah so don't put the
friends at you know dark political games
of so well you know the sentence is
really the guy that you know you know
he's gonna win and then they're going to
go after the sentence or the
establishment wants the Santas because
DeSantis is more establishment than
Trump is and it's easier to negotiate
with an establishment than it is to
negotiate with an anti-establishment
because one wants to drain the swamp the
other one is coming from the swamp
that's what some people are saying right
the Santas is kind of part of the swamp
who knows what's going on all I can tell
you is
a lot of this stuff here behind closed
doors there's a lot of talks and
negotiations going on that we probably
are not a part of and when we're not not
a probably not a part of we're not a
part of
um but this is this is the best this is
the one question nobody can answer me
here's a question for me that nobody can
answer okay
I had this girl Whitney Webb on very
smart girl okay wrote this books about
Epstein she lives in Columbia she's got
two kids doesn't want to live here she
feels safer over there in the podcast
she gets emotional I don't know if you
saw that she's just powerful who she is
how smart she is but she can't stand
Trump okay she can't stand the
establishment but she cannot stand Trump
so I asked her question I said I got a
question for you he says what's that I
said tell me the biggest institutions
departments that have made our lives
hell since
1963 November of 1963 why November 1963
November 22nd we know what happened I'm
saying November 1st of 1963. November
22nd JFK gets assassinated
and she says I said give me the names I
want to write them down that made our
lives a living kill okay CIA great who
else doj great who else well I would put
FBI but if he has part of the ocean okay
great what else you know NIH great what
else see these what else okay all of
this stuff that we're going through all
these at Federal Reserve all this stuff
that we're writing down okay great I
said now give me the families in the
last 60 some years since November 1st of
1960 that have made America worse off
have made our lives worse they've had to
control the establishment she's given
all these names the clintons we're going
through all of them right okay exactly
and then I asked the question I said now
tell me this
how many of these organizations love
Trump
she says to follow and she says I see
where you're going with this I said
there's only the closest example to
Trump is only one other name what's that
Bernie no it's John F Kennedy
I'll tell you why if you look at what
these guys wanted to do with the Federal
with the CIA with finishing the Vietnam
War we're doing all this stuff we can't
do are you kidding me the guy was
draining the swamp at the highest level
in Lyndon Johnson was the swamp he is
part of the oil guy he is a Texas guy he
was supportive of the war he was
supportive military industrial complex
and John F Kennedy's more from the
Eisenhower side saying listen we don't
need to go to war to make all this money
with the military why do we keep going
to war there's only the closest case
study you got to Trump is John F Kennedy
I'll give you another statistic here
watch this
um when John F Kennedy ran his dad
Joseph Kennedy gangster if you're not
study this guy one of the most powerful
men in America last hundred years oh
he's kind of like the uh Moses what's
his name uh
uh who's the guy in New York the power
broker Peter Moses Peter Moses something
like that so Robert Moses Roberts yes he
built New York pretty much right all the
stuff that he's hated and loved and
admired all of his sons okay Joseph
Kennedy at the time he's worth 400
million dollars in 1962. he says I
wanted to spend every single penny on my
life savings to make sure my son becomes
a president which son John F Kennedy not
the oldest one the oldest one was first
but he died but the plan the whole time
was the oldest was the oldest oldest one
dies yes in the war then they have to
make a fake War story for JFK yeah so
that he can actually win this guy is the
architect Joseph bro I mean
bro they like listen whoever's why do we
not have a movie
you need a movie about this guy I wonder
if they block it because the idea of the
Kennedy's right now is like this tragic
family that has went through all this
horrible stuff and we almost feel bad
for them but if you know what that
mother that that is a [__] if
you have a script you're watching this
up Joseph Kennedy send it our way 100
million dollars we're entertaining that
movie if you have a script anyways going
back to Joseph Kennedy 25 million bucks
for John F Kennedy's campaign okay
fifty percent of money for the campaign
was raised the other fifty percent was
John of Kent Joseph Kennedy's money okay
now watch History how much money who
raised okay Ronald Reagan put 9.6 of all
the money for his campaign okay 9.6 of
his own money the guy almost got
assassinated and killed uh did we go the
next one is is Ross Perot 97 of his
campaign money was his own money he went
up to 21 he didn't win but guess what he
caused George Bush Senior becoming the
President Clinton won if it's not for
parole bush is the president yeah the
director of CIA he's going to be the
president that's insane for an
independent to get 20 plus percent
in my as a kid I didn't know that how
rare that was and I was like oh this guy
got washed and no that's crazy Trump 72
percent yep 72 percent Hillary Clinton
zero
Biden Sarah they don't have to by the
way Bernie Sanders is also
anti-establishment but you know what he
did he caved at the end he did it should
have been Trump against burning Sanders
it should have never been he got scared
and they they did something behind think
they have something on Bernie that he's
embarrassed of because it should have
been the argument that we all wanted to
see let the two True Believers Bernie's
a True Believer socialist you know he
calls it socialist Democratic Socialist
and Trump is a troubling I want to see
that fight we've never got to see that
fight that was a that was a fight
Hillary Clinton wasn't really a fight so
when you look at some of this stuff and
you say why are these institutions do
you think it's some stuff from him
didn't he go over to Russia and like got
married there that's when his honeymoon
was out of Russia by the way so maybe
it's that maybe there's something
there's a [__] though we I mean America
gives a [__] I don't think they do no I
don't think they do I think the middle
of Russia let me tell you what let me
tell you what's one of the one the worst
places to be in okay here's one of the
worst places to be in my opinion
somebody calls you and they they they
have something on you you have a major f
up major screw up than you did and like
hey if you don't do this we're going to
go public with this okay
you sit there and you say okay
this is potentially going to cost me a
divorce
you know my kids I have to explain to
them I'm going to be it's going to be a
very embarrassing moment my kids here
my friends are going to say what the
hell were you thinking
that sucks and you're 62 years old
you're 71 years old I don't need to
freaking talk my legacy will be
protected forever or
if you're wise you're gonna say they're
going to bring it out anyways my kids
are going to know about it anyways you
know what I'm doing what I'm doing the
you know Eight Mile story yeah I'm going
to my kids and my wife and my family I
said listen guys we gotta have a meeting
here your father your father screwed up
19 years ago here's what I did boom boom
boom but I'm gonna go and tell the world
right now right afterwards and I'm going
to tell them they came and give me the
threat and this is what I'm doing and I
hope you take value now I'm going to
come out and say
let me tell you guys I got a
uncomfortable announcement to make and
then I hope you respect the fact that
I'm doing this because I don't want to
be held hostage you show a picture of
how hot the girl was because this is
like listen listen look at this listen
you would do it to America
that's huge that's a huge man you know
that's what Hugh granted right like he
got I think that the actor he got caught
with a prostitute and then went on
Letterman or something was like hey I
think they had already found out and
then he just owned it and then he had it
okay he reacted to the news coming out
but I jump in a gun on that is fire
going on Letterman to promote the movie
and then be like yo I got something else
to tell you yeah very disappointing but
go watch the movie
quick question about Trump's 71 percent
I don't know how to ask this about Sonic
super anti-trump but don't we not know
don't we know to not necessarily trust
his accounting and his numbers isn't he
kind of like doesn't have a history of
Legend numbers and so can I tell you
something here yeah so I I brought at
our vault conference last year uh this
year we're gonna have a Brady Tyson and
wilgudera from uh 11 Madison at the
event this year in Miami the chef the
chef yeah he'll be there so tell him to
put some meat on the menu
I was a little bit surprised I know but
it's not him now it's another person
that's using a menu apparently I don't
know she stepped away I don't know I
don't I think somebody told me that but
I want I want to answer this question
for you so you're asking about you know
accounting right okay
um
five years ago I'm at the Four Season
spot in Dallas and I'm doing a business
planning strategy session but I go to
the sauna downstairs and this guy's like
hey man I saw your interview with this
guy I'm like okay so what do you do I'm
an investment banker which firm such and
such oh cool how much money we do this
big guy in the 60s late 50s early 60s he
says I said uh what's the best speaker
you ever heard it says I've heard Tony
Robbins
I just got no one was a more
life-changing speaker I heard speak to
nandy fast though I said would you Andy
fast though
he said the antifaster I said Enron CFO
jail and yes
how is Andy faster the greatest speaker
you've ever heard he says he came in
this is a CFO of a company that's got a
hundred thousand employees working for
Enron and he gets up and he says here's
how this accounting World works
here's me recognized as the accountant
of the Year CFO
here's next month my card ID at the jail
I went from this to this now let me tell
you what happened he said I followed
every single guideline everybody else
followed and whatever everybody else was
doing we did it as well
but we for the same exact comparison we
got caught and here's what happened to
us
all of a sudden boom Enron he's going to
jail then they try to get his wife and
all this he does eight years anyways
he comes out now he's doing what he's
doing we got him at the event to speak
and tell the story because you have to
be careful when you make money who is on
your team
when so think about right now Elon
musk's life think about his life he's
running Tesla he's running Twitter he's
running SpaceX he's as I don't know how
many kids eight or nine kids
and he has to talk to his accountant and
he has to talk to this Goldman guy he's
Morgan guy and he has to follow the
accounting laws that are changing every
and
how do you like so okay I'm hiring this
accounting firm do I hire this forensics
to audit this accounting firm before I
hired accounting firm it is at the next
level it's very complicated I'm not
undermining anything there I think the
one angle you could have taken is to say
well yeah he funded 71 or 72 of his
campaign but isn't that from his
father's money because his father gave
him a million bucks or 10 million bucks
or 40 million bucks I can see that as an
argument you know to say he got money
for from his family but John F Kennedy
some Khan the greatest one the greatest
presidents we've had in the last 56
years
50 all the money was given by his dad he
didn't make his money at least Trump
operated and built some stuff these
names on these towers wasn't as dead
it's him putting the names on the towers
so yes I understand what you're saying
on the accounting side but I think it's
important for people to realize when
you're making five hundred thousand
dollars a year you have a very easy way
of doing your accounting also isn't
campaign Finance like uh super strategic
you can't just fluff numbers on your
campaign spending
yeah yeah then we wouldn't even have
the trial listen if they if they go that
route there's going to be 50 other
people right now running to Singapore to
make sure they're not next to
investigate them these guys are doing uh
what do you think happened on JFK
everything happened with JFK I'm not a
fan of Lyndon Johnson I'm not yeah you
know I'm always very careful with
super ambitious people
who are not talented
don't have charisma
and are not willing to work as hard as
you you have to be very careful with
them very
the most dangerous people people in
society are lazy ambitious people
oh my God they're dangerous distance
yourself from them stay you know stay
close don't offend them do your best to
not you know get on their bad side
because they're working 24 7 to come
after you
and to me
you know think about John F Kennedy
attractive good looking great last name
all the women love you Marilyn Monroe
Jackie Kennedy you're this freaking guy
that you're on cover of every single
magazine and there's this guy named
Linden
kid you wanted to be a president and
John F Kennedy didn't want to be a
president
John F Kennedy's father wanted the
oldest son to be President John F
Kennedy had back problems he had issues
he had things that he was dealing with
he was just a guy that wanted to live a
regular life
just always keep your eyes out on
lazy ambitious non-charismatic people
you think you think LBJ set them up if
I'm a betting man of course I can't say
100 but if I'm a betting man I'm gonna
say you know 60 yes it's him what chance
do you think it was that uh he was taken
out by Russia
uh from which standpoint from the angle
of
the fact that you know he had gone and
stayed in Russia and his girlfriend and
the wife and all that stuff you know
back in the days they were using this
one uh uh drug to get you not be
thinking what you're doing and then you
snap out of it again I don't know if you
experience so you know by the way this
is
this is the thing there's a reason why
this guy is a you know I call him one of
the sharpest cats on the market but he's
he's very good at uh you know she's
brilliant man what's he doing to you
right now what do you think listen what
game is he running he knows when we
finish the podcast how big of a fan I am
of his I think he's a modern day Johnny
Carson I think respect super capable I
think this is a guy that is a very
here's what I like with him this is what
I would like with them it's what he
wants but I would like to see Kim talk
to the average day-to-day people and
that happens at 11 o'clock at night
Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon a show when
Greg Gutfeld who's very good at
what he does you know he is the number
one beating out Fallon Kimmel you know
the only reason is because there's not a
letterman there's not a Leno there's not
a Johnny Carson today nothing against
him they got a great crew going on but
it just means the product of camel and
Fallon is not that good today that's
just all it means because you have
forgotten how to talk to the regular
person in America so the strength of
Ajani is I can talk with anybody but
most importantly I know how to talk to
America that's why people love them yeah
and I think he's the modern day Johnny
Carson where where was Johnny from oh it
was Omaha I think it was Omaha yeah I
think that was huge for Johnny I think
growing up there and understanding what
everyday people are
allowed him to communicate those
sensibilities to the people in Highland
in the highest echelons of Hollywood and
uh yeah even going back and like
watching him like unbelievably
charismatic self-deprecating imagine
being like the number one guy on
television when there's four channels
we're not talking about now when there's
like a million different channels about
different YouTube we're talking about
you are ubiquitous right and making fun
of yourself constantly a joke bombs on
TV every night you're teasing yourself
about doing it like a really special
person that I wish that this generation
could understand how he maintained like
his personal life may be wild and doing
some crazy [__] married four times all
that stuff yeah pulling the gun out on
the dude banging his wife whatever like
just a badass [__] but
but what he was able to do and how he
was able to keep relatively even Keel
with having that much influence power
and adulation is commendable not
everybody can handle success like that
you're 100 right
you're absolutely right and you know he
was one of a kind on how he did it so
going back to Russia you think Russia
was the I don't know it's just a tricky
situation because you can't acknowledge
that a foreign country killed your
leader without going to war and
everybody dying right so you have to
maybe make up a story that removes their
claim to Victory from them to protect
your national identity if it comes out
that we took them out you know like look
at what happened with Iran right when
Trump uh Zapped the dude and it puts the
American flag
but they said look what we did we
retaliated so they had to do that to
keep up there it's not fully money
because I'm full of money yeah so they
had to do it to keep up there you know I
guess morale image whatever it is
um but we I not only I guess struck
first but we took credit for it let's
say we didn't even do it
let's say they did it by accident
trumped on the flag up there
steals the story he's a marketer like
you know what I'm saying
when you had oil money
real and that's what that's how you know
Russia didn't want the smoke either
because if Russia did do it the fact
that they never claimed it means that
they don't want who better than foremost
think about who benefited the
establishment I I I'm with you on that
argument I think that you look at like a
lot of times throughout history
especially like when you start to delve
into conspiracy land conspiracy doesn't
mean something's not true but the way
that like certain presidents have been
attacked especially the ones that oppose
certain uh institutions you've spoken
about like Andrew Jackson is the number
one dude right ultimate guy yeah you're
right Jackson takes down the FED right
yeah and the way that we remember
Jackson is he's the most racist
president ever he hated Native Americans
it's like they all did
the idea that we're putting him on a
pedestal for being racist
story to kids it sticks yeah he reminds
me of this guy and this whole concept
with nationalism you know how the word
is a bad word being a nationalist what's
the what's the what's the antonym of
national what is the antonym of
nationalism globalism globalism okay so
listen I'm proud of being in that I love
my country I'm not going to be a
globalist yeah I've traveled the globe
don't level yeah
I'm a nationalist I am you look like I
get a blast in Morocco
I got the sweater
um uh can we say uh yeah we'll talk
about we're gonna go to well we'll go
wait we're gonna go to Turkey have some
fun in uh Turkey Istanbul or uh like pop
into assemble Bodrum have a nice little
summer yeah good bookstores there I
think you guys gonna enjoy the libraries
and uh yeah that's coffee yeah sure yeah
I believe it but I do I do like the way
that turkey is uh
I don't know I just love their their
role in history especially game chin
history you know you see all these
that's kind of the new conspiracy I'm
getting into the history before history
the history before history yeah
which part of Turkey
um oh God what's the name of it
well that well that there's there's one
site but there's like this specific area
where they have all these they've
discovered all these like cities that
are underground and they've been like
carved into the Bedrock and where people
would live and you're talking about some
of these cities are so meticulously
designed that they went down to the
water level and stopped right before the
water level so you had access to water
while you're underground and protected
from whatever was you know going on
upstairs and who knows what it was maybe
it was meteor showers maybe it was crazy
animals who knows but human beings went
underground for a stage in our existence
and we don't know why go for it to the
bottom of it we've got to figure this
thing out but oh I gotta send you I got
to get you down like a nice little
rabbit hole but this is the cool thing
about uh I think lately you know as we
discovered more about history the
timelines start to change you've seen it
with like the pyramids and all the
Egyptian stuff you know you should get a
guy named Graham Hancock on your pod
is he the guy the YouTuber with like six
million subs or something like that
there's a few other guys I mean we had
um you know who I'm talking about the
guy that does these history videos that
you know Uncharted X we had a guy named
Ben Van Kirk quick on who is fantastic
as well and it's just a bunch of these
guys who have studied these like um you
know ancient structures yeah and you
know part of the part of the analysis is
we don't think that this is physically
capable with a stone and a and a pick so
there had to be some sort of technology
or it had to happen way earlier and the
remnants of those civilizations is
completely wiped out which is kind of
exciting right don't you want to know
that this has happened all before how
different are we really like Mark you
were saying about when you went to pompe
have you been to Pompeii no but like you
okay Pompeii uh in southern Italy yeah
yeah it was it was covered by Mount
Vesuvius in like 32 A.D giant uh
eruption and then basically perfectly
preserved the city until it was
uncovered in like the 80s or 90s so it's
completely locked in right because it
was wiped out in a day everybody's
hanging out and then you see how they're
living and it's exact there's like a
[__] dick Museum there's like there's
brothels and stuff like that the
brothels all have like paintings of what
you can do because not everybody spoke
the language it was a big like a mariner
City but like prostitutes they wore
sandals with a symbol for prostitution
so you could follow where the sandals
were and you could find the prostitutes
that way they got fast food restaurants
and [__] and it's just like oh wow a few
thousand years ago they're living the
exact same way in many you know in
certain uh you know with with certain
things
Twitter spaces is the whole thing yeah
okay so all right where are we we're at
conspiracies you think it was
maybe these institutions maintaining
power okay come at it from another angle
the we can't sit here and believe that
like the course of America is plotted in
four-year increments right so in other
words like a new president comes in he's
like all right here are all my ideas you
go do it you've run businesses that are
incredibly successful you couldn't have
a new CEO pop in every four years and
then they work right you need a
long-term strategy right so you don't
think eight years is enough what I don't
think is that the president makes any
decisions you don't think he makes any
decisions I think they let him make a
few I think that's a good strategy you
just say what he says back to him and
then he's like
that's the question who is they
that is that is the fun one right there
who is they you know why isn't Epstein
arrested they know who's this guy who
just bought Epstein's Island and why are
we letting him buy it and why didn't we
all buy it
why didn't me you Rogan and other rich
people that can foot the bill go and buy
the island and then explore it for
ourselves we'll find something there a
retainer case you know like because like
I guess who is the day that's the
exciting one now honestly if you can
answer that question who is they yeah
you can answer a lot of different things
then they will kill you
yeah and he shows what a great guy we're
here at his funeral
I can't say much more because they are
here
I don't know do you believe American can
change like you don't believe that
there's a long-term strategy that you
have people maybe in the state
department or the CIA or the FB I don't
even know if the FBI would work in that
way but there's a longer geopolitical
strategy that's attached to this country
I was hoping I've played a dark role
what is the outcome what do they want to
do preserve America and it's a dark side
the Dark Souls so yeah yeah maintenance
because American Supremacy allows their
businesses to flourish a lot a lot of
people have said that you know the CIA
in a lot of ways operates in the
interests of these billion dollar
corporations and I'm not just talking
about like the ones that make the bombs
and stuff you might have a corporation
that's selling bananas that come from
Nicaragua you control the money you
control the world exactly yeah so it's
like hey all of a sudden Nicaragua wants
to make a country out of itself well
that [__] up my banana business hey CIA
guy can you do me a favor
yeah like and then they might go in
there put somebody else in power and who
knows maybe that's beneficial to America
in some way we consume a lot of the
bananas and we need them to get out of
Nicaragua I don't know but there has to
be somebody or a group of people and I'm
sure some of them are you know connected
to politics maybe these like lifelong
politicians like a Nancy Pelosi type
it's like what is she she's a House of
Representatives she's not even a senator
right she was she was but she's in a
house so she got a campaign every two
years really this old lady is gonna run
around every two years for 40 years to
maintain this shitty little seat in the
House of Representatives she got to be
part of something bigger right like it
doesn't make sense to me you know they
just had the meeting right the the the
meeting in Europe
what is it called no not the doubles
there's another one that just happened
right now this week where uh not the G7
not the G7 the one where they're all
sitting around saying uh um you'll see
if you pull it up the the AI and they
had all these different issues and they
went through this used to be a secret
society meeting where nobody would talk
about it publicly now they're no longer
saying it uh they're saying this meeting
was being done here uh used to be in San
Francisco I want to say the Bilderberg
oh the Bilderberg conference was not in
like Sweden or Norway or something
Sweden or Norway so I think it yeah I
think it's Sweden but and they wrote out
exactly who was there what the topics
are what the issues are oh there's some
good conspiracy stuff about this
conference yeah Zeitgeist it was in
Zeitgeist was that a change or one of
those yeah yeah okay going on so the
whole thing is like who is they our day
day or is there a guy that's like okay
uh have those guys sit right next to
each other why is that person you're
going invited them okay I see why we
have him he needs to meet with him
because we need to get that deal because
we need that technology here for South
Africa because of the deal that we're
doing with India so they like who is
they they really that's what I'm saying
yeah who is it and who continues to hire
these people and how do we make sure
that we have the best talent how do
those people get recruited you think
there's a couple different days yeah I
know so I think that there's this is my
hope and I know this sounds crazy to
Hope but like I I think that my hope is
is that there is a group of people that
are the vase that we're thinking about
right and these people probably work for
government institutions maybe some of
them are politicians maybe you want some
that are in and they're like the career
politicians that you're like why haven't
you done more like why are you like why
is Nancy Pelosi
campaigning every two years like you're
too famous to campaign like why not go
for what be a senator campaign every six
years it'll just be easier power job the
speaker of the house is a very powerful
but she wasn't always speaker right yeah
she was in politics forever forever so
so you have a few of those people and
they plot the course of America and
those people interface with the billion
dollar corporations that are that are
incredibly successful within America my
assumption is is that once you're a
Bezos once you're an Elon you're a
government employee and not in a bad way
but it like
hang on gaining money and gaining
influence and being successful Google
has to talk to the government so I got a
question for you yeah do you do you
think Elon uh his vision with what he's
doing is good like if I were to ask you
what percentage of trust you have that
Elon is a good person trying to do good
versus evil what would you say I think
and the best
um I think he believes that he's doing
the right thing and I think that
sometimes comes at odds with the powers
that be and I think that's why you see
like for example everybody loved Elon
Elon was the darling there was the left
and the right the left we're buying his
electric cars and the right was like
here's this businessman he's making all
this money we love him it was the one
thing the left and the right could come
together on a ground and then Elon gave
a political opinion he tweeted it's hard
for me to I'm a lifelong Democrat it's
hard for me to consider myself a
Democrat now and just like anytime Joe
Rogan says that he supports a
presidential candidate or anybody with
influence and you're going to go through
this as well there was a smear campaign
that happened the day after and they
were out there they whoever they is out
there trying to make him radioactive
maybe that's the DNC maybe it's not even
the vase that we're talking about maybe
that's much lower level yeah maybe
that's like DNC to me is like low level
[__] it's like you're trying to get
someone in his office like that's not
the game we're playing this is that's
temporary game Davis that's forever game
they days are like manifest destiny like
we want to go back they days are like yo
let's buy Louisiana are you saying like
Coke you're talking about Roth's child
you're talking about people talking
about those types of guys I think those
are the guys that get to interface with
the government employees right because
you need someone who's actually part of
the fabric of the government and then
you have so much success within business
that you become part of the government
so Google can't operate on its own the
government needs to know what Google
knows and Google is like you know what
that's fine because otherwise I go to
prison or whatever the [__] it is
Zuckerberg gets a call everybody gets a
call right like we even saw it with
Twitter right it wasn't like the FBI
interfacing with Twitter
so we know that they're discussing
things and we know things are going on
and like to be honest that's why I think
you're in the best position where it's
just like you have
generational wealth because if you
wanted to stop right now you're good
your kids will be good your kids kids
will be good and obviously hopefully you
put the values in them to make sure they
make these smart decisions like you have
real Freedom right now that you have
real freedom on planet Earth that is
[__] crazy that is like point zero
zero zero zero zero one percent of human
beings even get care the only way to get
there without money is like if you could
live off the land and [__] that I'm not
trying to Camp every single day you know
what I mean I want air conditioning I
want a [__] house right so
once you get to
multi-billionaire status now you get the
calls from those days and you'll find
out who these are but you got to be
willing to pay the cost and that they
might call you and be like listen
Trump ain't the guy man he's messing up
these deals that are 50 years in the
making like he's talking about buying
green land we've been trying to buy
Greenland for 1905. well we think we'll
get it by 2030 and he's talking about it
now now the price is going to go up and
they don't even realize the resources
they have under there but this [__]
baboon started talking about it and that
like there has to be somebody who
decided we need to go from New York to
California so you think there's an
element of nobility in the establishment
I here's the thing due to money because
the selfishness yes of making sure to
protect the money there's a nobility in
your business succeeding because the
people that work for you yeah also
succeed and they Thrive within that
business so like you wanted to succeed
is going to help them pay for their
families and everything now I'm not
saying they make the right decisions
they make [__] horrible decisions
that we benefit from and we just get to
complain and whine about them because
we're on the right side they go start
some War somewhere we take all the oil
oils two dollars a gallon we get to take
all that oil enjoy all that oil at two
dollars a gallon and still go
they suck are they gonna make those Wars
over there I don't piece of [__] days
and they can't even complain about it so
so money keeps them honest they're
selfish uh uh intentions and desires
makes them do the right thing so okay so
then the question becomes are they more
driven by Freedom status or control
I would assume the latter control you
could say they're one of the same yeah
they could all be wrapped up in a one I
assume these people are are patriots
they just have a different way of
looking at their patriotism